[Musica]
faceva caldo quel giorno il mare era
molto più vicino rispetto a quante oggi
era la prima volta che partecipava a un
Ted come ospite non vi nascondo che è
strano stare dall'altra parte
soprattutto quando dall'altra parte sta
oltre 2000 metri tu soffri di vertigini
e tra l'altro c'è un gran bel vento
era un periodo di vita in cui cercavo
cambiamento ma non sapevo bene da dove
partire
come quando hai tutti i pezzi di un
puzzle sai che vuoi costruire una
macchina ma ti manca proprio l'immagine
della macchina per iniziare a incastrare
i pezzi
ricordo bene quel giorno la quantità di
idee stimoli nuove conoscenze che mi
portai a casa mi fu subito chiaro che se
volevo raggiungere obiettivi diversi
dove iniziare a fare cose diverse
Peccato solo che a casa ci torno a piedi
perché la macchina quella vera con cui
c'era andata Me l'avevano rubata Tra
l'altro penso che loro non servisse
neanche per chissà quali ispirazione per
un puzzle Comunque da quel giorno sono
cambiate tante cose esattamente un anno
fa ieri al caos di una startup ho
aggiunto una dose di entropia non
indifferente diventando papà è un po'
tutti gli equilibri che fino a quel
momento avevo composto ci sono
totalmente scomposti oggi voglio
parlarvi di tre analogie che col tempo
durante questo periodo ho iniziato a
vedere in questi due aspetti della mia
vita che in fondo
forse non sono così lontani per farlo
useremo un elemento della natura e uno
sport che sono in realtà molto lontani
da dove siamo oggi ma molto vicini a me
Quanti di voi hanno fatto per alzata di
mano almeno una volta nella vita surf
pensavo peggio
Allora il surf idealmente si può
dividere in tre macro momenti che
potremmo chiamare la preparazione
l'attesa e l'azione
facciamo uno sforzo immaginiamoci su una
spiaggia davanti a noi le onde ci siete
voi una tavola forse una muta di vedervi
dall'acqua sarà per il contatto
epidermico che abbiamo con questa
attrezzatura ma vi assicuro che si
diventa una cosa sola è per quello
bisogna sceglierla bene una tavolo un
po' più grande ci farà sicuramente
galleggiare meglio lo sforzo sarà anche
minore ma con onde alte sarà impossibile
da manovrare come una muta un po' più
calda in giornate torride sarà
impossibile da tenere addosso
allo stesso modo investitori in una
startup guardano più al Team che
all'idea stessa soprattutto nelle prime
fasi si dice che è meglio un'idea
mediocre non ti informidabile che il
contrario
in realtà non è tanto il talento del
singolo Ma quanto quel gruppo di persone
bravo a comporsi e a lavorare bene
insieme come un'unica entità forse sarò
banale però dico sempre che non c'è un
momento giusto nella vita per diventare
genitori in realtà non si è mai pronti
è una scelta che va fatta più di pancia
che di testa l'unica cosa giusta Secondo
me avere la persona giusta a fianco
non c'è una ricetta per essere buoni
genitori o un unico founder sicuramente
essere complementari coprirsi le spalle
arrivare dove l'altro magari non arriva
è già un buon punto di partenza fiducia
rispetto sono due pilastri fondamentali
nel rapporto si è sottoposti uno stress
incredibile si prendono un sacco di
decisioni molto spesso in tempi
brevissimi quindi inevitabilmente si
finisce con litigare però bisogna farlo
con intelligenza Non possiamo Non fare
il latte perché siamo arrabbiati quando
non possiamo fermare un'azienda perché
la pensiamo in modo diverso
soprattutto i primi giorni i primi
periodi i primi mesi una startup
nonostante il tuo bigliettino da visita
avrà un ruolo ben definito
le tue giornate saranno incredibili la
mattina Magari sarà il designer a pranzo
porti fuori un cliente pomeriggio
Rispondi alle mail di supporto e la sera
si è fuori con un investitore il giorno
dopo tutto il contrario dovrei essere
bravo a coprire tutti gli spazi finché
non trovate qualcuno che ti può
sostituire farai tante cose tante ti
piaceranno tante vanno fatte perché si
dovranno fare e ti sporcherai tanto le
mani anche questo un parallelismo
Ok entriamo in acqua Io solito faccio un
gesto del genere un po' così ad
accarezzare il mare Un po' un rituale in
realtà stiamo facendo una cosa che è
totalmente anti intuitiva rispetto al
nostro istinto di sopravvivenza inizio a
nuotare tra le onde
il frastone tale che Ci obbliga a
trattenere il turbinio dei nostri
pensieri in spiaggia lasciamo tutto il
mondo fuori quasi meditativo poi a un
certo punto arriviamo in quella che è la
linea di rottura la cosiddetta Line up
tutto
improvvisamente si calma su un silenzio
a tratti disarmante tu sei là guardarti
in giro fare quello che viene detto
leggere le onde che significa un po'
imparare il linguaggio del mare capire
cosa Sta per succedere
Ecco il linguaggio è quella capacità che
permessa all'uomo nei millenni di
evolversi organizzarsi è un po' La dote
che ci ha permesso di sovrastare tutta
il resto delle altre specie animali non
so se ve ne siete mai accorti ma i
neonati non parlano di solito piangono
in un asse che va da tanto tantissimo
e tu devi essere lì a capire perché devi
Scomporre in realtà quel linguaggio e
capirne in realtà quelli che sono i
messaggi sottesi devi capire qual è la
differenza tra un pianto persone e un
pianto per fame Magari stropicciarsi gli
occhi può essere un buon indizio è lo
stesso modo quando inizia a inserire
persone all'interno dell'organizzazione
il tuo ruolo diventa un po' quello di
essere un traduttore fare parlare far
prendere decisioni a persone che hanno
punti di vista sulla vita background
linguaggi totalmente diversi ho imparato
a mie spese
Non uscire mai dalla stanza quando c'è
un commerciale e uno sviluppatore che
stanno cercando di risolvere un problema
di solito è l'eterno dilemma draghi crea
E chi vende e non troveranno mai un
punto di contatto
un altro aspetto interessante del
linguaggio e anche quello di allineare
il linguaggio interno dell'azienda al
resto del mondo è un qualcosa di
veramente sottovalutato nelle Startup di
solito impieghiamo tanto tempo a
allineare quelle che sono le
funzionalità del nostro prodotto i
nostri servizi a quello che pensiamo ai
nostri consumatori il mercato possa
volere ma non dedichiamo abbastanza
tempo ad allineare il linguaggio molto
spesso ci
arrocchiamo su parole sofisticate Quasi
autocelerative scordandoci di vocaboli
semplici che ci sono nella testa dei
nostri consumatori che ci aiuterebbero
tantissimo nel vendere O comunque fare
adottare il nostro prodotto perché fatto
la comunicazione non è tanto quello che
diciamo Ma cosa le persone capiscono
usciamo dall'acqua ci guardiamo un po'
in giro Cerchiamo la tavola siamo appena
caduti da un'onda il surf è uno degli
sport con la curva di apprendimento meno
ripida di tutti imparare un lunghissimo
susseguirsi di onde in faccia fatica e
tanti errori l'errore è diciamo un
pilastro fondamentale sia nella crescita
di un bambino sia in una startup Quando
iniziamo a camminare cadiamo spesso è
normale Le persone intorno a noi battono
le mani ci incitano a riprovare però non
si sa perché quando cresciamo ce ne
scordiamo se ci scordiamo che l'errore È
un pezzo fondamentale in un processo di
apprendimento abbiamo un fortissimo
retaggio culturale che ci porta a
chiamare esperimenti quelli che fa la
scienza mentre invece errori o peggio
fallimenti quelli che fa il business
ci ricordiamo che se vogliamo imparare
tanto e in fretta inevitabilmente
l'errore non sarà una parte disgregante
del processo di apprendimento manasserà
la parte centrale in area ci diciamo
sempre che se abbiamo tutto sotto
controllo in realtà lo stiamo andando
così veloce pensate che quando inizi a
crescere un po' come abbiamo fatto noi
puoi assumere persone a ritmo di una
persona e mezza a settimana
a questi ritmi è devi mettere in conto
che quello che stai costruendo la tua
organizzazione i flussi processi sono
destinati a saltare in aria dalla tre
mesi è normale e tu mi devi essere lì a
ricomporre tutto quello che si è appena
scomposto imparando dagli errori che hai
fatto e per assurdo devi essere felice
perché se non fosse così non stai
crescendo abbastanza Ora voi Mi direte
Ok facile parlare col senno del poi vi
assicuro che non è così anche perché
mentre scrivevo questo discorso è
capitato nuovamente quindi il karma mi
ha messo un po' lo zampino
il problema reale Secondo me è che
usiamo allo stesso modo due termini che
sono sbagliare ed errare quando in
realtà è una etimologia molto diverse
sbagliare è più vicino
all'essere distratto che un abbaglio
mentre rare ha una terminologia
totalmente diversa molto più vicino a un
tema dell'esplorazione andare in random
andare vagando Andare senza meta perché
in realtà tutto poi è una meta il surf e
anche lì uno sport strano perché il
campo di gioco dove ti muovi e non una
permutazione continua Non ci saranno mai
due onde uguali mai due condizioni
atmosferiche uguali e penso che sia uno
dei pochi sport che è diciamo a queste
condizioni Quindi tu sei lì
continuamente ad esplorare un nuovo
mondo intorno a te una nuova ambiente
come fanno i bambini i bambini esplorano
in continuazione perché il mondo per
loro è totalmente nuovo e imparano
continuamente e lo possono fare perché
hanno i genitori che dall'altra parte si
occupano di tutto quello che la loro
sopravvivenza Ecco nelle startup in
realtà l'esplorazione è una parte
fondamentale per capire il tuo posto nel
mondo di solito i genitori in questo
caso si chiamano fondi di venture
Capital oppure un trucco che abbiamo
imparato è quello di iniziare a vendere
qualcosa mentre capisci cosa in realtà
devi vendere così conosci i tuoi clienti
magari fai anche un po' di cassa e vai
piano piano costruendo esplorando e
facendo errori Quello che in realtà poi
è il prodotto finale
Ecco quindi potremmo dire che in realtà
figli start up non sono poi così diversi
ci sono un sacco di libri di corsi su
come fare delle ottime startup Come
essere dei buoni genitori in realtà
penso che nessuno potrà mai dirci la
verità Non perché non ci sia una verità
ma perché ognuna di queste è una storia
a sé e in quanto tale va vissuta quello
che di sicuro so è che
in fondo fai cose di cui non sei tanto
sicuro vai un po' A tentativi impari
facendo tutti ti fanno i complimenti poi
alla fine le notti in bianco siete da
soli
Inoltre voglio essere onesto con voi Ho
iniziato a usare la metafora del surf un
po' per caso per cercare un immaginario
collettivo che ci potesse guidare in in
questo viaggio insieme mentre scrivevo
il discorso vedevo Come in realtà Questi
pezzi si univano bene anche questo terzo
aspetto della mia vita forse aveva tanti
aspetti in comune con gli altri due di
sicuro richiedono un grandissimo sforzo
tanta tanta fatica ma in cambio di un
anno tante soddisfazioni
in tutti arrivi a fine giornata che sei
distrutto ma se ti guardi indietro e
vedi che ti sei divertito in fondo ne è
valsa la pena Poi se trovi la macchina
posteggiate anche meglio
Grazie